For many American families, the past two and a half years have been a time of economic turmoil. At the beginning of the pandemic, millions of workers lost their jobs and hourly workers in service industries were especially hit hard. Now unemployment is down, but inflation is up, and so are fears about a possible recession. This kind of instability and economic hardship affects more than just workers themselves. When people lose their jobs or have to cope with unstable, work schedules and incomes. The effects spill over to their families, their children, even entire communities. Research has linked job loss to everything from mental health problems to children's lower test scores in school. So how have workers, especially low-wage workers and their families,
对许多美国家庭来说，过去两年半是一个经济动荡的时期。在大流行初期，数百万工人失业，服务业的按小时计酬工人受到的打击尤为严重。现在失业率下降了，但通货膨胀上升了，人们对可能出现的经济衰退的担忧也随之增加。这种不稳定和经济困难不仅影响到工人本身。当人们失去工作或不得不应付不稳定、不规律的工作日程和收入时，这些影响会波及他们的家庭、孩子，甚至整个社区。研究表明，失业与从心理健康问题到孩子在学校考试成绩下降等各种问题都有关。那么，工人们，特别是低薪工人和他们的家庭，
fared over the past two and a half years? How are they doing now compared with March 2020? Did government interventions such as expanded unemployment insurance and other programs make a difference in people's lives. And what is needed now? More broadly, what have researchers learned from the pandemic that could inform employment and economic policies going forward? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is Dr. Anna Gassman-Pines, a professor of public policy, psychology, and neuroscience at Duke. University. Her research focuses on how work and employment and welfare policies affect families,
在过去两年半里过得怎么样？与2020年3月相比，他们现在情况如何？扩大失业保险和其他项目等政府干预措施是否对人们的生活产生了影响？现在还需要什么？更广泛地说，研究人员从大流行中吸取了哪些教训，可以为未来的就业和经济政策提供参考？欢迎收听《心理学说话》（Speaking of Psychology），这是美国心理学协会（American Psychological Association）的旗舰播客，探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。我今天的嘉宾是杜克大学公共政策、心理学和神经科学教授安娜·加斯曼-派恩斯（Anna Gassman-Pines）博士。她的研究重点是工作、就业和福利政策如何影响家庭、
family life, and well-being, particularly for low-age and hourly workers. Since the start of the COVID-19 pandemic, Dr. Gassman-Pines has also been closely following how job loss, childcare interruptions, and other pandemic-related disruptions have affected these families. Her research has been supported by grants from the APA, the National Science Foundation, the National Head Start Association, and the National Institute of Mental Health, among others. Thank you for joining me today, Dr. Gassman Pines. Thank you so much for having me. For the past couple of years, you've been studying how the COVID-19 pandemic has affected
家庭生活和福祉，特别是对低薪和按小时计酬的工人。自新冠疫情爆发以来，加斯曼-派恩斯博士还一直在密切关注失业、托儿中断和其他与大流行相关的干扰是如何影响这些家庭的。她的研究得到了美国心理学协会（APA）、美国国家科学基金会（National Science Foundation）、全美头雁计划协会（National Head Start Association）和美国国家精神卫生研究所（National Institute of Mental Health）等机构的资助。谢谢你今天加入我们，加斯曼-派恩斯博士。非常感谢邀请我。在过去的几年里，你一直在研究新冠疫情是如何影响
low-wage working families. In a lot of ways, this work started because you were in the right place at the right time. Can you tell us about that? Who are the people you've been following over the course of the pandemic, and what are the research questions you've been asking them? Sure. So the work that I've been doing during the pandemic actually started way before the pandemic was even a glimmer in anyone's eye. I had been planning a study really trying to understand both how common, unpredictable, and unstable work schedules are for low-wage workers in the service sector,
低薪工薪家庭的。在许多方面，这项工作之所以开始，是因为你在正确的时间出现在了正确的地点。能跟我们讲讲吗？在疫情期间，你一直在跟踪哪些人？你一直在问他们哪些研究问题？当然可以。我在疫情期间所做的工作，其实在大流行甚至还没在任何人脑海中萌芽之前就已经开始了。我一直在规划一项研究，真正试图了解服务行业的低薪工人的工作日程到底有多普遍、多不可预测和不稳定，
the consequences of those unpredictable work schedules for family well-being, and whether policy changes that aim to regulate work schedules could improve. improve working conditions and possibly improve family well-being at the same time. And so to do that work, my colleague Elizabeth Ananat and I recruited a sample of about a thousand hourly service workers who are working in retail jobs, in the food service sector, and in hotels, all of whom who had a young child between the ages of two and seven, because that's the time for parents when navigating and negotiating and negotiating and balancing work and family is particularly challenging. And the goal was to follow those workers over time to ask and understand those research questions.
这些不可预测的工作日程对家庭福祉的后果，以及旨在规范工作日程的政策变化是否能改善工作条件，并同时改善家庭福祉。为了开展这项工作，我和同事伊丽莎白·阿纳纳特（Elizabeth Ananat）招募了大约一千名从事零售业、食品服务业和酒店业的按小时计酬的服务工人样本，他们都有一个两到七岁的小孩子，因为对父母来说，在这个时期驾驭、协商和平衡工作与家庭是特别具有挑战性的。我们的目标是随着时间的推移跟踪这些工人，以提出并理解这些研究问题。
We did this work in the city of Philadelphia because the city of Philadelphia was about to implement a new policy called the Fair Workweek Standard that was going to start regulating work schedules for hourly service workers in April of 2020. We went back into the field shortly before then in February of 2020. to do another round of data collection with these families. And so we were actually in the field surveying these parents about work, about their well-being, about family life, right at the moment that so many of us remember so well when everything changed,
我们在费城进行了这项工作，因为费城即将实施一项名为“公平工作周标准”（Fair Workweek Standard）的新政策，该政策将于2020年4月开始规范服务业按小时计酬工人的工作日程。我们在2020年2月不久前重新进入现场，与这些家庭进行另一轮数据收集。因此，我们实际上是在实地调查这些父母关于工作、关于他们的福祉、关于家庭生活的情况，就在我们许多人记忆犹新、一切都改变的那一刻，
when schools closed, when stay-at-home orders were issued, when non-essential businesses were closed. And we were really able to see, with those survey resources, responses almost in real time as our own lives as working parents was turned upside down, just how quickly these families' lives were turned upside down, how quickly people lost connections to work, and how much family well-being suffered in the immediate aftermath of all of those closures and changes. So what are the factors that were most salient as you were looking at all of this?
学校关闭了，居家令发布了，非必要企业关闭了。借助这些调查资源，我们几乎能够实时看到——正如我们这些作为职场父母的生活被彻底颠覆一样——这些家庭的生活被颠覆得有多快，人们失去与工作的联系有多快，以及在所有这些关闭和改变的直接后果中，家庭福祉受到的损害有多大。那么，当你审视这一切时，最显著的因素是什么？
What were the outcomes that you found? We asked parents about their own mood. How are they feeling? Are they feeling anxious, depressed, worried? We asked them how their children were doing. So for young children, sometimes if they're feeling anxious or worried, they might cry or be clingy, the way that adults might be. But sometimes when young children are feeling stressed or worried, they act out. So they might be uncooperative, for example.
你发现的结果是什么？我们询问了父母们关于他们自己的情绪。他们感觉如何？他们感到焦虑、抑郁、担忧吗？我们询问了孩子们的情况。对于幼儿来说，有时如果他们感到焦虑或担忧，他们可能会像成年人一样哭泣或黏人。但有时当幼儿感到压力或担忧时，他们会表现出来。例如，他们可能不合作。
And so we asked parents about whether their children had been. more uncooperative or whether they had seemed more worried or sad. And what we saw is that in the early phase of the pandemic, both parents' mood and mental health was worse, and so was children, right? So parents were telling us their children were more uncooperative than usual. They were seeming more sad and worried. And that was particularly true for families who were really hard hit in those early days in the pandemic. So families where the parents were doing more care work, whether for children or older adults, where parents had lost jobs, where families had lost income, where people in that family had been feeling sick, those things really accumulated.
因此，我们询问了父母孩子们是否更加不合作，或者他们是否显得更加担忧或悲伤。我们看到的是，在疫情早期，父母的情绪和心理健康都变差了，孩子也是如此。因此，父母告诉我们，他们的孩子们比平时更不合作。他们看起来更悲伤、更担忧。对于在疫情早期受到沉重打击的家庭来说，情况尤其如此。也就是说，父母承担更多照顾工作（无论是照顾儿童还是照顾老年人）、父母失业、家庭收入减少、该家庭中有人感到生病的家庭，这些事情确实累积起来了。
And when families experienced multiple hardships related to the pandemic, both parents and children's mental health was much worse in those early days. Over the course of the pandemic, government programs tried to buffer people against some of the effects that you're talking about. Programs like expanded unemployment insurance and SNAP benefits, which help people buy food. Did the people in your study actually benefit from these programs? Did the programs make a difference that you could really measure and see? We were able to ask folks about a lot of different supports that they might have received from the government during the pandemic. So you mentioned some of them. Expanded eligibility and
当家庭经历与疫情相关的多种困难时，在早期，父母和孩子的心理健康都变得要糟糕得多。在疫情期间，政府项目试图帮助人们缓冲你所谈到的一些影响。诸如扩大的失业保险和帮助人们购买食物的SNAP福利（补充营养援助计划）等项目。你研究中的人真的从这些项目中受益了吗？这些项目是否产生了你可以真正衡量和看到的差异？我们能够向人们询问他们在疫情期间可能从政府获得的许多不同支持。所以你提到了其中一些。扩大的资格和
generosity of unemployment insurance, SNAP benefits, single stimulus payments. There were several times during 2020 and 2021 when the government simply sent checks to people around the country, and also the child tax credit where eligibility was expanded and it went from a lump sum payment to a monthly payment for the last six months of 2021. Taken together what we see is a few things. So number one, those policy supports did make a huge difference for families, especially in terms of buffering very large income losses. So this was a time when many of the parents in our sample had been laid off, or those who were still working had had their hours reduced. And so those set of government supports definitely buffered large income losses. They also reduced material hardship, so things like reporting that your family doesn't have an
失业保险的慷慨程度、SNAP福利、单次刺激性付款。在2020年和2021年期间有几次，政府只是向全国各地的人们寄送支票，还有儿童税收抵免，其资格扩大了，并且在2021的最后六个月里，它从一次性付款变成了按月付款。综合来看，我们看到了一些事情。第一，这些政策支持确实对家庭产生了巨大的影响，特别是在缓冲非常大的收入损失方面。因此，这是一个时期，我们样本中的许多父母被解雇了，或者那些仍在工作的人的工作时间减少了。因此，这一套政府支持肯定缓冲了巨大的收入损失。它们还减少了物质困难，比如报告说你的家庭没有钱买食物，或者你担心钱会花光买不起食物，或者担心付不起房租。因此，这套政府支持也减少了物质困难。我们还有一些证据表明，特别是像扩大的失业保险这样更慷慨的政策，也改善了心理健康，特别是对被解雇的工人而言。这些福利的发放时间怎么样？关于人们何时获得某些东西，你发现了什么？事实是，这些福利之一就是你所谈论的儿童福利，它曾经是一笔过，然后按月发放。这有很大的区别吗？你能看看以前是一笔发放时发生了什么，然后随着它按月发放，发生了什么变化吗？是的，我们仍在研究这个具体问题，但其他研究人员，包括我的同事和合作者伊丽莎白·阿纳诺（Elizabeth Ananate），也一直在使用其他数据源来研究这个问题。我们从心理科学和社会科学对这一问题的研究中了解到的是，那些按月发放的儿童税收抵免确实减轻了有孩子的家庭的经济困境和物质困难。现在，你已经研究了SNAP福利的时效性，以及一个家庭何时拿到这笔钱，如果它在月初到来，随着时间的推移，孩子们会发生什么变化？
money for food or that you're worrying that you're going to run out of money for food or worrying that you can't pay enough rent. So the set of government supports reduced material hardship as well. And we also have some evidence that especially the more generous policies like the expanded unemployment insurance also improved mental health, especially for workers who had been laid off. What about the timing of these benefits? And what did you find with respect to when people are getting certain things. The fact that one of these benefits was the child benefits that you were talking about, it used to be a lump sum, and then it was given on a monthly basis. Did that make a big difference? Could you look at what was happening before when it was a lump sum, and then what
或者是担心买不起食物，或者是担心房租不够付。因此，政府的一系列支持措施减少了物质困难。我们也有一些证据表明，特别是那些更慷慨的政策（如扩大的失业保险），也改善了心理健康，特别是对那些被解雇的工人而言。这些福利的发放时间是怎样的？关于人们在什么时候能领到某些东西，你们有什么发现？事实上，其中一项福利就是你们刚才谈到的儿童福利，它过去是一笔总付金额，后来改为按月发放。这有很大的区别吗？你们能否研究一下以前作为总付时的情况，然后看看
happened as it was being doled out on a monthly basis? Yeah, so we're still working on that specific question, but other researchers, including my colleague and collaborator, Elizabeth Anonaut, have also been looking at that using other data sources. And what we're learning, from across the psychological science and social science of this issue is that those monthly child tax credit payments definitely reduced financial distress and material hardship for families with children. Now, you've looked at the timing of SNAP payments and when a family gets that money, if it comes at the beginning of the month, and what happens to the children over the course
在一个月里？随着这笔钱的花费，他们过得怎么样？因此，我在工作中发现的一件事是，SNAP福利对低收入家庭来说是极其重要的支持，但它们无法维持整个月。因此，它们旨在维持整整一个月，但它们往往会用完，对于大多数家庭来说，大约两周后就会用完。
of that month? How are they faring as the money is being spent? So one of the things I found in my work is that SNAP benefits are the children. are a really crucial support for low-income families, but they don't last the whole month. So they're designed to last for a whole month, but they tend to run out, and they run out for most families after about two weeks.
这意味着在那个月的后半段，当这些福利已经用完时，这些家庭的情况实际上与前半段有很大不同。首先，父母们更加担心是否有足够的钱买食物，实际上在某些情况下，他们报告说吃得更少，或者如果他们有更多的钱，他们会吃得跟他们更愿意吃的不同类型的食物。父母报告说更多地依赖其他营养援助来源，
And so what that means is in that second half of the month, when those benefits have run out, things are actually really different from those families than they are in the first half of the month. So first of all, parents are much more worried about having enough money for food, and actually in some cases report eating less or eating different types of food than they might prefer if they had more money available. Parents report relying more on other sources of
比如向朋友和家人借钱，或者使用其他非政府支持，比如孩子学校的背包计划。最后，我还表明，这些事情可以共同积累，并实际影响孩子的考试成绩。因此，当孩子们在一个SNAP月份结束时坐下来参加年底的考试，比如全国公立学校学生参加的阅读或数学成就测试，如果他们坐在那里参加考试在SNAP月份结束时，他们的表现实际上比他们坐在那里参加测试时稍微差一点在他们的家庭获得这些福利之后。其中一些孩子依赖于在学校吃免费午餐，然后他们就不在学校了。那么钱去哪儿了？你必须支付在其他地方支付的餐费。没错。因此，我在我一直在做的其他工作中发现的是，当学校关闭时，对于依赖学校餐食和学校提供的其他种类的营养支持的家庭来说，那是一个特别脆弱的时期，比如周末把食物送回家的背包计划。我的同事和我实际上已经证明，就在学校关闭的那一刻，在3月中旬，对于依赖学校餐食的低收入家庭来说，食品不安全感在这些学校关闭后大幅增加。现在，我要说的是，在大流行期间，政策发生了变化，这也试图增加对依赖学校餐食的家庭的营养支持，主要是通过基本上向家庭支付学校本用来购买学校午餐和学校早餐的食物的钱。但是，当然，这些款项直到几个月后才到账，而且就在学校关闭的时候，家庭立刻就有食物需求。是的，那么你的大流行研究如何与我们从先前研究中了解到的关于人们对福利计划的需求相吻合？是什么让这些程序或多或少有效？因此，我们在大流行期间学到的东西在几个方式上不一定是什么全新的东西，而是真正使事情变得更清楚，真正照亮了我们之前一直在学习的一些东西。例如，失业保险系统是我们失业时的主要政策反应，但它的设置很难访问。这个想法是，这是许多州政策制定者做出的政策选择。这个想法是，如果我们使这难以访问，那么只有真正需要它的人才会通过圈套和障碍来获得他们的福利。实际上发生的情况是，那些挣扎最多的人，
nutrition assistance like borrowing money from friends and family or using other non-government supports like backpack programs at their child's school. And finally, I've also shown that these things can together accumulate and actually affect children's tax. test scores. So when children sit down at the end of a snap month to take a end of the year exam, like a reading or math achievement test that public school students across the country take, if they're sitting down to take that test at the end of the snap month, they actually do slightly worse on that test than if they would have sat down to take that test right after their family got those benefits. And some of these kids were relying on getting free lunches at
营养援助，比如向亲友借钱，或者使用其他非政府支持（例如孩子学校的背包计划）。最后，我还发现这些事情可以累积起来，并实际影响到儿童的考试成绩。因此，当孩子们在一个“食品券”周期的月末坐下来参加期末考试时（比如全国公立学校学生都要参加的阅读或数学成就测试），如果他们是在“食品券”周期的月末参加考试，他们的成绩实际上会比在他们家庭刚领到这些福利之后参加考试时略差一些。其中一些孩子原本依靠在
school, and then they weren't in school anymore. So what happens to the money? You've got to cover meals that were being paid for elsewhere. That's right. And so what we've found in other work that I've been doing is that when schools closed, that was a particularly vulnerable time for families who were relying on school meals and other kinds of nutritional supports that were provided through schools, like backpack programs where food gets set home on the weekend. And my colleagues and I have actually shown that right when schools closed at that same moment in mid-March, for low-income families, who were relying on school meals, food insecurity increased substantially after those schools were
学校吃免费午餐，后来他们不用去学校了。那么钱去哪儿了？你必须支付原本在别处解决的餐食。没错。因此，我们在其他研究中发现，当学校关闭时，对于那些依赖学校供餐以及学校提供的其他营养支持（例如周末带食物回家的背包计划）的家庭来说，这是一个极其脆弱的时期。我和我的同事实际上已经证明，就在学校关闭的那个时刻（3月中旬），对于依赖学校供餐的低收入家庭来说，在学校关闭之后，粮食不安全状况显著增加。
closed. Now, I should say that there have been policy changes during the pandemic that have also sought to increase nutritional support for families that were relying on school meals, primarily by essentially paying families out the money that schools would have used to buy the food for school lunch and school breakfast. But of course, those payments didn't come until several. months later, and right when school's closed, families had food need right away. Yeah, so how does your pandemic research fit in with what we know from previous research about what people need from benefits programs? And what makes these programs more or less effective? So there are several ways in which what we've learned during the pandemic
现在，我应该说，在大流行期间也发生了一些政策变化，这些变化也试图增加对依赖学校供餐的家庭的营养支持，主要方式是基本上把学校原本用来购买学校午餐和早餐的资金直接支付给家庭。但是当然，这些款项直到几个月后才发放到位，而就在学校关闭的时候，家庭立刻就需要食物。是的，那么你的大流行病研究如何与我们从以往研究中了解到的关于人们对福利程序的需求相契合？是什么让这些程序更有效或效果较差？我们在大流行期间学到的东西有几种方式
isn't necessarily something brand new, but really making even clearer, really shining a light on some things that we had been learning before. So, for example, the unemployment insurance system is our main policy response when people are laid off from jobs, but it is set up to be difficult to access. And the idea of that is that's a policy choice that many state policy makers have made. And the idea is, if we make this difficult to access, then only the people who really need it will go through the hoops and the hurdles to get their benefits. What actually happens in practice is that the folks who are struggling the most,
面对最多的生活挑战，因此最需要支持的人，往往在获得福利方面遇到最多的困难。实际上是那些更有优势的人，他们有更多浏览复杂系统的实践和支持，才是能够实现获得这些福利的目标的人。这一切在新冠疫情期间变得更具挑战性。所以这里有一个被设置为难以访问的系统。突然间，在2020年有这么多人被解雇，需求巨大。
who are facing the most life challenges and therefore need to support the most, often have the most trouble accessing benefits. And it's really people who are more advantaged, who have more practice and support for navigating complex systems are the ones that can achieve the goal of getting those benefits. and that all became much more challenging during COVID. So here's a system that is set up to be difficult to access. All of a sudden there was a huge need in 2020 where so many people were being laid off.
而这个系统根本没有被设置为用户友好、顺利和易于人们通过。这些障碍在疫情之前就已经存在，在疫情期间变得更具挑战性。因此，一个教训是，你知道，我们可能会反思，这是我们真正希望变得更容易的支持吗？有办法减少所谓的行政负担，使政府项目更容易让人们访问。
And the system was just not set up to be user-friendly, to be smooth, and to be easy for people to get through. And those barriers already existed before the pandemic and were really made much more challenging during the pandemic. So a lesson is, you know, we might reflect on, is this the kind of support that we want to actually make easier? There are ways of reducing so-called administrative burdens to make government programs easier for folks to access.
这是一个我们可以决定的政策选择。你看到这种情况发生了吗？还是说这真的是立法者不得不介入并承担责任的情况？是的，我的意思是，我认为，你知道，实地有很多倡导者，我也知道，他们做真正重要的工作，阐明其中一些问题，特别是让州立法者了解这些支持的重要性，了解使它们更容易访问的重要性。而且，你知道，我认为大流行在许多方面所做的一件事是帮助很多人看到，有时会有我们控制之外的环境。例如，这确实改变了我们的工作生活，或者确实改变了我们对照顾支持的需求。这可能发生在任何人身上。这不仅是穷人的事。这不仅是按小时计酬的服务工人的事。
And that's a policy choice that we, you know, that we could decide to make. Did you see that happening? Or is that really a case of legislators having to step in and carry the water on this? Yeah, I mean, I think, you know, there are a lot of advocates on the ground who also, I know, do really important work shedding light on some of these issues for especially state legislators to understand the importance of these supports, to understand the importance of making them easier to access. And, you know, one thing that I think the pandemic has done in many ways is helped lots of folks to see that sometimes there are circumstances outside or control. that really change our work lives, for example, or really change our need for supports for caregiving. And that can happen to anyone. It's not just poor people. It's not just hourly service workers.
希望我们能够反思这一点。展望未来，考虑如何让这些程序在需要时更容易让许多不同的人访问。自从大流行前以来，你一直在研究失业和经济衰退。所以让我们更广泛地谈谈这项研究。你的一些特别有趣的发现在于失业如何影响整个社区。你发现，当一个地理区域内有大量失业时，它会影响整个社区，甚至是没有失业的人。
And hopefully we'll be able to reflect on that. And moving forward, think about ways to make these programs easier for lots of different people to access when they need them. You've been studying job loss and economic recessions since before the pan. So let's talk a little more broadly about that research. Some of your findings that are especially interesting center around how job loss affects whole communities. And you have found that when there's a lot of job loss in a geographic area, it can affect an entire community, even the people who haven't lost their jobs.
而且它会以非常广泛的方式出现。你能谈谈你发现了什么吗？当然。所以我的同事和我做了一系列的研究，真正突出了大规模裁员的方式，当社区中的许多人在社区中失去工作时，会对整个社区产生各种连锁反应，远远超出了受影响的工人本身。我想我们所有人都能在大流行期间更多地看到这一点。但在大流行之前也是如此。
And it can show up in very wide-ranging ways. Can you talk about what it is that you found? Sure. So my colleagues and I have done a series of studies that really highlight the ways that that large-scale layoffs when lots of people in a community lose jobs, that has all kinds of ripple effects throughout the community that go well beyond the workers themselves who are affected. And I think we can all have all been able to see that so much more during the pandemic. But it was true before the pandemic too.
例如，我在这里，在杜克大学。我在北卡罗来纳州。北卡罗来纳州曾经拥有大量的纺织制造业，北卡罗来纳州有许多社区，社区中的许多成年人在纺织厂工作。当这些工厂关闭时，很多人失去了工作。现在，并不是社区中的每一个成年人，因为当然，仍然有警察、教师、护士，对吧？但尽管如此，当发生大规模失业时，社区中的许多人同时失去了工作。
So, for example, I'm here at Duke University. I'm in North Carolina. North Carolina is a state that at one time had a tremendous amount of tech. textile manufacturing, and there were many communities in North Carolina where lots of adults in the community were working in textile mills. And when those mills closed, lots of people lost work. Now, not every adult in the community, because of course, there were still police officers, teachers, nurses, right? But nevertheless, when there were large-scale job losses where a lot of people in the community lost work at the same time.
它改变了青年对他们生活中可以去哪里的很多看法，对吧？所以环顾四周，说，好吧，我的父母还在工作，但我看到我的同学或朋友，对吧，或者我的同龄人的父母刚刚在那个纺织厂失去了工作。那是一份我认为可能永远存在的工作。现在我不知道这是不是，你知道，那对我来说不再可用了。许多家庭都经历过经济压力，尽管这些成年人继续工作。所以也许是那个女服务员，她的餐馆在纺织厂街对面，
It changed so many things about how youth imagined where they could go in life, right? So looking around and saying, well, my parent is still employed, but I'm seeing my classmate or my friend, right, or my peers' parent has just lost a job at that textile mill. That was a job that was, I thought, might always be there. And now I don't know if that's, you know, that's not available to me anymore. A lot of families experience economic strain, even though those adults continue to work. So maybe it's the waitress whose restaurant was across the street from the textile mill,
人们不再过街吃午饭了。所以她带回的小费变少了。尽管她还有工作，但她的收入下降了。这个家庭可能会感到更加紧缩，并感到更多的经济压力和担忧。因此，不仅是受影响的工人，而且实际上，你知道，这些从中心向外扩散的连锁反应确实对其他成年人有害，特别是对这些社区的青年。我想你还发现了一些对大学入学率、儿童考试成绩甚至自杀率等事情的影响。听起来非常广泛
and folks aren't coming across the street for lunch anymore. So she's taking home less than tips. Even though she still has a job, her earnings have gone down. And that family may be feeling more crunched and be feeling more economic strain and worry. So it's not just the affected workers, but actually, you know, these ripple effects. that go out from the center and can really be harmful for other adults, but also for, especially for youth in those communities. I think you also found some impacts on things like college attendance, children's test scores, and even suicide rates. It sounds like it's very widespread
而且很复杂。没错。所以，对于青少年来说尤其如此。青少年是年轻人弄清楚关于他们身份的很多事情的时期。他们将成为什么样的人，你知道，作为一个成年人，儿童期和成年期之间的这种桥梁，很多反思我是谁，什么对我很重要，我的教育和职业目标是什么。我们在工作中发现的是，当出现这些全社区范围的失业时，这些社区中的青年会受到各种方式的影响。我们发现青年的考试成绩受到了影响。因此，处于社区中刚刚经历过这些失业的青少年在这些阅读和数学成就测试中表现更差。他们上大学的可能性变低了，对于低收入青少年来说尤其如此。他们有更多的心理健康问题。对女孩来说尤其如此。但是，你知道，这是一次非常紧张的经历。同样，身处一个正在经历这种变化的社区，许多成年人和同龄人都受到影响，我们确实看到，当青年生活在一个经历过这些大规模失业的地方时，真正严重的心理健康问题，比如考虑自杀，实际上上升了。为什么女孩更容易受到影响？我只是好奇想知道这一点。你有什么想法吗？所以这是我们，你知道，考虑了很多的事情。这是关于女孩在多大程度上将她们的感情内化，以及当她们感到压力时，这些是由于不同的社会化造成的。其中很大一部分被保留在里面。男孩也许更有可能将这些感觉外化，以不表现出来的方式，你知道，不是在抑郁或自杀中，而是在其他表现出来的行为中。所以可能会有，你知道，几个不同的原因。你长期以来一直感兴趣的另一个领域是不可预测和混乱的工作日程如何影响人们的家庭生活和他们的孩子。现在，作为一个作为记者做了多年轮班工作的人，我可以告诉你，这在身体上
and complex. That's right. So, and this is especially true again for for adolescents. So adolescents being a time when young people are figuring out so many, things about their identity. Who are they going to, you know, who are they going to become as an adult, this kind of bridge between childhood and adulthood, so much reflecting on who am I going to be, what's important to me, what are my educational and career goals. And what we found in our work is that when there are these community-wide job losses, youth in those communities are affected in a range of ways. So we find that youth's test scores suffer. So those same kind of end grade reading and math achievement tests. Adolescents perform worse on those tests when
而且很复杂。没错。所以，对于青少年来说，情况尤其如此。青少年时期是年轻人摸索自己身份认同的时期。他们要成为什么样的人，你知道的，作为一个成年人他们会变成什么样，这是童年和成年之间的一座桥梁，他们会反思我要成为谁，什么对我很重要，我的教育和职业目标是什么。我们在工作中发现，当出现全社区范围的失业时，这些社区的青少年会以各种方式受到影响。我们发现青少年的考试成绩受到了影响。也就是说，那些期末的阅读和数学成就测试。青少年在这些测试中的表现会更差
they're in a community that's just experienced these job losses. They become less likely to go to college, and that's particularly true for low-income adolescents. And they have more mental health problems. That's particularly true for girls. But, you know, this is a very stressful experience. And again, to be in a community that's going through these kinds of changes where so many adults and peers are affected, we did see that when youth are living in a place that's experienced these large job losses, really serious mental health problems, like considering suicide, actually go up. Why would girls be more affected? I'm just curious to know about that. Do you have any ideas? So that's something we've, you know, wondered about quite a bit. Is it differences in
当他们身处一个刚刚经历这种失业潮的社区时。他们上大学的可能性会降低，对于低收入青少年来说尤其如此。他们的心理健康问题也更多。对女孩来说尤其如此。但是，你知道的，这是一次压力非常大的经历。而且再次强调，身处一个正在经历这种变化的社区，如此多的成年人和同龄人都受到影响，我们确实看到，当青少年生活在一个经历过如此大规模失业的地方时，像考虑自杀这样非常严重的心理健康问题实际上会上升。为什么女孩受到的影响更大？我只是对此感到好奇。你有什么想法吗？所以这是我们，你知道的，思考过很多的事情。这是因为……的差异吗？
how much girls are kind of internalizing their feelings and when they're feeling stressed, those are kind of because of different socialization. A lot of that is getting kind of kept inside. Boys perhaps might be more likely to externalize those feelings in ways that show up, you know, not in depression or suicide, but in other kind of acting out behavior. So there could be, you know, several different reasons. Another longstanding area of interest for you has been how unpredictable and chaotic work schedules affect people's family life and their children. Now, as someone who spent years on shift work as a reporter, I can tell you it is physically
是惩罚性的。但关于对家庭和孩子的影响，你的研究发现了什么？几件事。我的意思是，我们发现的一件事是，特别是对于服务工人，对于从事低薪工作的员工，在零售、食品服务、酒店。不可预测的工作日程非常普遍。所以这只是拥有这些工作的一部分。例如，我们做的一件事是要求人们每天回答这些简短的调查，持续整整一个月。
punishing. But what have you found in your research regarding the effect on families and children? Several things. I mean, one thing we find is that especially for service workers, so for folks working for low wages, in retail, in food service, in hotels. Unpredictable work schedules are incredibly common. So this is just part of what it means to have those jobs. So for example, one thing we do is we ask folks to answer these short surveys every day for a whole month.
所以我们正在获取关于每天发生的事情的非常详细的信息。你去上班了吗？你什么时候开始和停止的？这些是原本在你的日程表上的时间吗？如果你没有工作，你应该工作吗？日程表上有被取消的班次吗？我们发现，在10%的日子里，这些工人的日程安排发生了一些意外的变化，无论是工作时间的改变、取消的班次，还是最后一分钟增加的班次。所以10%听起来可能很低，但是，你知道，那是每个月三天，每个月，对吧？事情没有按计划进行，然后这给家庭带来了连锁反应，因为必须重新安排托儿服务，对吧？所以如果你增加了一个原本不在发布的原始日程表上的班次，突然有人告诉你，我们明天早上需要你上班，现在就需要争先恐后地寻找托儿服务。因为，同样，我们样本中的父母有不能独自留下的幼儿。他们需要某种照顾。所以一件事是这是非常普遍的，当它发生时，它会导致各种其他挑战，特别是围绕寻找照顾孩子的问题。这对父母来说压力极大。因此，父母报告说，当这种情况发生时，与同一父母在工作按计划进行的日子相比，他们的情绪要糟糕得多。因此，当我们获得这些详细的调查报告时，我们实际上能够比较，对吧？
So we're getting really detailed information about what happened every day. Did you go to work? When did you start and stop? Were those the hours that were originally on your schedule? If you didn't work, were you supposed to work, had shifts been on the schedule that got taken off? And what we find is that on 10% of the days, these workers had some kind of unexpected change to their schedule, whether it was a change in hours, a canceled shift, a shift that got added on at the last minute. So 10% might sound low, but, you know, that is three days out of the month, every month, right? something did not go as planned, and then this causes a ripple effect for families in terms of having
因此，我们获得了关于每天发生的事情的极其详细的信息。你去上班了吗？你什么时候开始和结束的？这些是原本排在你的日程表上的时间吗？如果你没有工作，你应该工作吗？日程表上原本有后来被取消的班次吗？我们发现，在10%的日子里，这些工人的日程表发生了某种意料之外的变化，无论是工作时长的改变、被取消的班次，还是最后一分钟增加的班次。所以10%听起来可能很低，但是，你知道的，每个月有三天都是这样，每个月都如此，对吧？有些事情没有按计划进行，然后这会给家庭带来连锁反应，导致
to rearrange child care, right? So if you get a shift added on that wasn't on the original schedule that was posted, and all of a sudden you're told, we're going to need you to work tomorrow morning, now there's a scramble for finding childcare. Because, again, the parents in our sample have young children who cannot be left alone. They need to be in care of some sort. So one thing is this is incredibly common when it happens, it leads to all kinds of other challenges, especially around finding care for children. And it is incredibly stressful for parents. So parents report much worse mood on days when this happens compared to the same parents on days when work goes as planned. So when we get these detailed survey reports, we're actually able to compare, right?
在一个你按照原本日程表上的时间工作的日子里，你的感觉如何，与被告知需要呆到很晚或者被提前送回家的日子相比如何？压力太大了。父母报告说情绪糟糕得多。我们也看到了一些新出现的证据，它与你自己的个人经历有关，即当工作日程改变时，父母的睡眠质量也受到了影响。在发生这种意外变化的日子里，父母说他们睡得更差。你之前提到了宾夕法尼亚州的公平工作周法律，你正计划研究，
How do you feel on a day when you work, the hours that were on that schedule originally, compared to a day when you get told that you need to stay late or you get sent home early? And it's incredibly stressful. And parents report much worse mood. We're also seeing some emerging evidence, and it relates to your own personal experience, that parents' sleep quality is also affected when their work schedules are changed. and on days with these kinds of unexpected changes, parents say that they're sleeping worse. You mentioned earlier the Fair Workweek Law in Pennsylvania that you were planning to look at,
其中一些法律可能会解决这些问题。关于这些法律运作得如何以及它们是否对人们的生活产生影响的研究有哪些？我们在费城的工作正在进行中，但我可以告诉你，我们在加利福尼亚州埃默里维尔市也做了一个较小版本的这项工作，该市是通过公平工作周政策变化的早期领导者之一。我们在埃默里维尔发现了几件事。首先，埃默里维尔公平工作周条例减少了我刚才描述的那种不稳定的工作日程的情况。
and some of these laws may address these problems. What is the research into how well these laws work and whether they make a difference in people's lives? So our work in Philadelphia is ongoing, but I can tell you, we also did a smaller-scale version of this work in the city of Emoryville, California, which was one of the early leaders in passing a fair work week policy change. And what we found in Emoryville are several things. So first of all, the Emeryville Fair Workweek Ordinance reduced the instances of the kinds of unstable work schedules that I just described.
所以在埃默里维尔，非常非常小的企业，那种家庭经营的企业不受该条例的管辖，但较大的企业受管辖。所以我们能够做的是查看工作日程的差异。小企业和大企业之间的日程安排，在法律变更之前和之后。我们看到的是，基本上在该法律生效后，大企业的工作日程变化立刻减少了。所以它们最终看起来更像小企业。因此，在法律生效后，这种不稳定工作日程的情况要少得多。这些法律是如何运作的？你真的可以对一个企业说，你不能安排
So in Emoryville, very, very small businesses, kind of family-run businesses weren't covered by the ordinance, but larger businesses were. And so what we were able to do is look at differences in works schedules. schedules between the small businesses and the larger businesses, both before the law change and after. And what we see is basically that after that law went into effect, those changes to work schedules decreased right away in the large businesses. So they end up looking a lot more like the small businesses. And so those instances of unstable work schedules are much lower after the law goes into effect. How do those laws work? Can you actually say to a business, you can't schedule
某人在早上7点停止工作，然后在晚上7点回来，就像航空公司为了让人能够飞行而不坠机所做的那样。没错。所以这些法律的运作方式是，它们在现行的不同城市中略有不同，但它们具有大致相同的总体结构。结构的工作方式是，他们说，好吧，大型雇主，你需要给你的工人一定数量的提前通知他们的工作日程。所以有时是10天，有时是14天。你需要把那个日程表贴在一个对所有员工都可见的地方。
somebody to stop work at 7 o'clock in the morning and then come back at 7 o'clock at night, like what airlines do to keep people able to fly and not crash the plane. That's right. So the way these laws work, and they're a little bit different in the different cities where they are on the books right now, but they have the same sort of general structure. And the way the structure works is, they say, okay, large employers, you need to give your workers a certain amount of advance notice of their work schedule. So sometimes it's 10 days, sometimes it's 14 days. And you need to post that schedule in a place that is visible to all employees.
如果你想在10天或14天内更改日程表，没关系。但你需要对这些日程变更对人员进行补偿。这是非常关键的区别。所以这并不是说你永远不能更改工作日程，甚至是最后一分钟的更改。但它所说的是，如果你需要更改日程表，你必须对这些员工进行补偿，因为他们在制定生活计划。他们根据你最初发布的内容保留了那个时间。然后补偿意味着什么，再次，有点不同。
And if you want to change the schedule within the 10 or 14 days, that's okay. But you need to compensate people for those schedule changes. That's the really crucial difference. So it's not saying you can never make a change to the work schedule or even a last minute change. But what it is saying is that if you need to change the schedule, you have to compensate those employees because they were making their life plans. They were holding that time based on what you originally posted. And then what the compensation, what that means also, again, kind of varies.
但它可能会说，例如，看，如果你取消某个人的班次，你必须支付他们一半的班次，因为他们在他们的日程表上保留了那个时间。所以如果你要取消它，他们需要因为保留了那个时间而得到补偿。如果你想增加班次的小时数，你可能需要支付一点额外的费用，几乎像加班一样。同样，因为那是个人最初没有计划的额外时间。事实证明，雇主在改变员工班次时真的不想付钱。新出现的证据是，他们实际上宁愿坚持提前发布的班次。因此，例如，在埃默里维尔，取消班次的情况有所下降，因为据推测这些雇主不想因为取消班次而不得不支付补偿。
But it might say, for example, look, if you cancel someone's shift, you have to pay them for half of the shift because they were holding that time on their schedule. And so if you're going to cancel it, they need to be compensated for having held that time. If you want to add hours to a shift, you might need to pay a little bit of extra, almost like overtime. Again, because those are additional hours that the person wasn't originally scheduled. And it turns out that employers really don't want to have to pay when they change people's shifts. The emerging evidences, they would actually rather stick with the shifts that are posted in advance. And so, for example, in Emeryville, the instances of canceled shifts went down because presumably those employers did not want to have to pay that compensation for having canceled a shift.
当前似乎无法逃避的一条经济新闻是通货膨胀。我知道这真的不是你必然在工作的领域，但我只是想知道是否有任何研究，如果你看到任何关于通货膨胀对人们心理健康和福祉的影响的迹象，或者现在说还为时过早？是的，我的意思是，我认为可能会有更多关于通货膨胀的心理科学和社会科学问世。但我能说的是，你知道，对于低薪工人来说，甚至在大流行之前，他们就生活在有很多不稳定因素的日复一日中。许多人的工作班次可能会改变，
One piece of economic news that seems inescapable right now is inflation. I know that's not really an area where you're necessarily working, but I'm just wondering if there's any research, if you're seeing anything regarding the effects of inflation on people's mental health and well-being, or is it just too soon to say? Yeah, I mean, I think there's probably going to be a lot more psychological science and social science coming out about inflation. But what I can say is that, you know, for low-wage workers, even before the pandemic, they were living day-to-day with a lot of precarity. So many people have jobs where shifts might get changed,
工作时间可能不规律，可能还有其他工作压力源。但对于那些从事高薪、高收入工作的人来说，通常有很多不同的方法来缓冲这种不稳定或不可预测的一些负面影响。对于低薪工人来说，情况从来都不是这样。因此，任何使这种平衡行为变得更加困难的变化都会增加这些家庭的压力和经济实力。所以我可以想象，例如，我们会了解到，而且我确信现在就是这样，对于收入较低的人来说，通货膨胀在他们维持家庭基本需求和平衡工作与照顾竞争需求的能力方面确实产生了影响。
hours might be irregular, there may be other work stressors. But for folks who are in higher wage, higher earning jobs, there's often a lot of different ways to buffer some of the negative effects of that instability or unpredictability. For low wage workers, that's never been the case. And so any changes that make that kind of balancing act more difficult are going to increase stress and financial strength for those families. So I can imagine, for example, that we will learn, and I'm sure it's true right now, that for people with lower incomes, inflation is really making a difference in terms of their ability
那么你的研究下一步是什么？你是否在继续追踪自大流行开始以来你一直在追踪的家庭？我们刚刚完成了我认为将是我们对这些人进行调查的最后一轮。我们非常感谢我们研究中的家庭在充满挑战的时期陪伴了我们两年半。我们现在正在做的是一本书长度的项目，真正试图将这一切整合在一起，既了解大流行的难度，也了解这些非常规政策反应确实对家庭生活产生了影响。希望通过反思我们所学到的一切。
to meet their family's basic needs and to balance the competing demands of work and care. So what's next in your research? Are you continuing to follow the families you've been following since the beginning of the pandemic? So we've just finished what I think will be our last round of surveying these folks. We are just so grateful to the families in our study for having stuck with us for two and a half years through a very challenging time. And what we're working on now is a book-length project, really trying to put it all together, both to understand how difficult the pandemic was, but also the way that these unconventional
在过去的两年半里，这项研究可能会真正为一个不同的前进方向提供线索，这将为低收入家庭在未来提供更强大的安全网以及更多的稳定性和可预测性。加斯曼-派恩斯博士，谢谢你今天加入我们。
policy responses really did make a difference in family's lives. And the hope is by being able to reflect across all that we've learned. over the last two and a half years, this research might really shed light on a different path forward that will provide a stronger safety net and more stability and predictability for low-income families into the future. Dr. Gassman Pines, thank you for joining us today.
这真的很有趣。谢谢。非常感谢邀请我。您可以在我们的网站 www.w.compan 上或在 Apple、Stitcher 或您获取播客的任何地方找到《心理学说话》的往期节目。如果你喜欢你所听到的，给我们留个评论。如果您对未来的播客有评论或想法，您可以发送电子邮件至 speaking of psychology
This has been really interesting. Thank you. Thank you so much for having you. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at www.w.compan or on Apple, Stitcher, or wherever you get your podcasts. And if you like what you hear, leave us a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology
在 APA.org。Speaking of psychology 由 Lee Weinerman 制作。我们的声音编辑是 Chris Condyenne。感谢收听。我是美国心理学协会的 Kim Mills。该剧集尚无评论。点击成绩单中的任意句子发表评论。
at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Weinerman. Our sound editor is Chris Condyenne. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
访问 APA.org。Speaking of psychology 由 Lee Weinerman 制作。我们的音响剪辑师是 Chris Condyenne。感谢您的收听。我是美国心理学会的 Kim Mills。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。